you know what i would prefer queen bee
did
actually instead of what they do now i
would prefer that if queen bee animated
their dojins or animated their hentai
the same way
that um animated dungeons are made no
kind of like uh what was that uh house
uh the yuck is a husband one i got
animated oh where the hell's husband
where where the house husband yeah you
know
slide shows yeah not slideshows just
like an animated comic i would actually
prefer
that style over where they just copy
each frame
whether you just copy each phrase
because because to me like a motion
comic would
give way more of like an impact than
what whatever the [ __ ] queen bee do yeah
like please queen b
please i i i could i can handle that
just just give me a motion call me queen
how much how much
how much you need like 20 bucks
[ __ ] you know yeah i mean like uh i
wrote eight out of ten because of lolly
but i'll probably give it a nine
it would have been a 10 out of 10 if
there was no laws honestly i'm not
joking that's serious
would you be interested in his other
works then other is this
good yeah this artist is really good
most of his work is very [ __ ]
oriented
he's just
you know [ __ ] is like the best
visually part like the visually like
sexual thing [ __ ] is probably the
most attractive looking i think
when done right yeah yeah it's like a
it's like a what's like a macaroon
there's little [ __ ] sweets you know
what i'm going with this
you always see those sweets right you're
like the french fries
because you look at a macaroon right
you're like that looks amazing that's
[ __ ] amazing
i really really want that and they never
ever ever taste as good as they look
and that's how i feel about blue really
yeah really
yeah why because in in
why it hence bro they make it look like
[ __ ] wrestlemania smackdown whirlwind
on the dick
it's not like that in real life it's
like oh [ __ ] you know
you've been no [ __ ] it's not what it's
like that's not what it is that's what
it looks like in the entire race it's
very aggressive it's very aggressive
but i mean actually a lot of work
sometimes you know sometimes it's
awkward you just realize that you're
just standing there and you're just like
oh [ __ ] it's
awkward isn't it so much work you know i
mean it's just
like sometimes sometimes like what's so
great about [ __ ] is that there's
literally no pressure to do
anything you know right because you know
sometimes sometimes i get that moment
where like i get distracted for one
second and i get taken out of it i'm
like [ __ ]
[ __ ] i had to do my taxes [ __ ] no no no
now i got to pretend like i'm still i'm
still there i'm still in the zone
oh yeah oh oh
[ __ ] i really got a father's taxes
though [ __ ] i really forgot about that
oh god i can't do it now can i it's
going to be really awkward if i if i go
and do those now
babe can i hear my laptop real quick
i'm just going to follow his taxes
but yeah that's good